hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir uns zu einem neuen video
wird eingeblendet ich will euch heute 10
pokémon zeigen wie es wirklich im real
life gibt partner von sin echt ekelhaft
und bleibt unbedingt bis zum ende dran
weil ich werde am ende ein gewisser
bleibt auf jeden fall dran ist cool
das erste buch das ich wollte mir
vorstellen wäre es kurze ist es nicht
niedlich croxall ist nämlich eine
kaulquappe ich glaube das sagt der name
halt auch schon so ein bisschen
allerdings keine normale kaulquappe
sondern eine lichtdurchlässige
kaulquappe ich zeige euch gleich mal die
gegenüberstellung der beiden pokémon
dann seht ihr euch was ich meine
außerdem haben schwarze kapuze und knapp
ja auch an dem bauch irgendwie solle
spirale
die ist nicht da weil sich die
entwickler von pokémon dachten okay das
sieht irgendwie cool aus letzte weiße
fläche sondern das ist wirklich bei
diesen lichtdurchlässigen kaulquappen
dies im echten leben gibt der darm
ich zeige euch mal die gegenüberstellung
nächste pokémon um das heute geht ist
raub ii ich denke jeder kehrt robbie
zumindest seit pokémon black and glaub
ich wirklich jeder dieses pokémon weil
es einfach zusammen mit hollywood aux
die habitat am häufigsten in dem spieler
auftritt also ich hasse robbie
mittlerweile stört dieser folge damit
war man nur zwölf wochen kamen dicken
creek dpa das sagen wirklich sehr viel
die pokémon go spielen so von wegen
jakob sie robbie holdings und megageil
werde von denen nur vier pokémon
brauchst dann kannst du schon eins
entwickeln aber ich spiele pokémon
derzeit nicht mehr auf level weil ich
bin derzeit nämlich 25 oder 26 level
dann halt mehr darauf dass ich jetzt den
pokédex irgendwie versuche voll zu
kriegen natürlich ist es schwierig aber
zurück zum thema braucht ist wie es der
name halt auch schon sagt eine raupe
allerdings uns genau zu fassen die
papilio blockus du bist deutsch außerdem
eher traurige augen und in der serie ist
so das rwi ab und zu wirklich mal
blinzelt oder halt irgendwie so wirklich
dadurch guckt oder so und bei der raupe
die ich euch gleich als
gegenüberstellung zeigen werde sind
diese augen nur man kann sagen
aufgedruckt aber das ist halt ein tier
diese papiere glaube es kann auf jeden
fall durch diese augen nicht sehen aber
ich zeige euch jetzt wenn die
gegenüberstellung damit ihr wisst was
ich meine
das nächste buch das ich zeige dir opi
und das ist glaube ich diesmal mit das
einzige pokémon was nicht aus der ersten
generation stand die ich euch heute
zeige auf deutsch übersetzt ist ein
mexikanischer schwanzlurch und der tritt
eigentlich auch nur als dauerläufer auf
als er macht sich jetzt nicht irgendwie
schön oder so 15 date mit einem anderen
fischer sowie trophy hat japan weiter
entwicklungen in den pokémon spiel
deswegen das gibt's bei den
mexikanischen schwanzlurch leider nicht
aber ich zeige euch jemand die
gegenüberstellung
das nächste pokémon kennen eigentlich
definitiv jeder und zwar wird es von
einigen geliebt von vielen gehasst es
ist ein cartago hardcover dorf das cover
d'or ist nämlich ein yellow rock fisch
oder auf deutsch übersetzt 1 sebastian
barry muss diese deutsche sprache ist
echt beschissen wer denkt sich jetzt
erstmal so crazy bastrop kinos oder
jedem rock fisch es wird jetzt an die so
eine kleine kleine fischarten sollen
lokale und her spielen
visa europe fisch ist sowas von viel
krasser alten körper dorf ich zeige euch
jemand die gegenüberstellung das nächste
pokémon das heute gehen soll ist chlor
wie so gehe ich immer so komische uplink
ceo ist eine riesen rafflesia und
rasiere ich keine ahnung wie's richtig
ausgesprochen wird ich habe mir notizen
zu jemals im pokémon gemacht das ist die
größte pflanze der welt
die reden sondern sie wie twitter
eigentlich komplett ähnlich und sogar
das runde ding was da so in der mitte
oben ist bei die flosse team eigentlich
komplett gleich nochmal die blüten von
dieser pflanze können bis zu einem meter
durchmesser erhalten und sie kann bis zu
elf kilo schwer werden hier mal die
gegenüberstellung
das nächste pokémon ist planer geil oder
blau dabei ist ein vogel und zwar das
schwarz köpfchen das ist eine typische
papageienart eigentlich die fahrer
aufteilung ist quasi genau gleich werden
blau dabei also der plauderei hat halt
noch irgendwo ein komisches ding auch
ein koch unserem komischen schwanz mit
seinem dicken dingen drin
es gibt kein vogel der so etwas
komisches hat die schwarz könnten bis zu
15 zentimeter groß und ich glaube der
serie sieht man das plaudern bei
teilweise wirklich größer ist als die
köpfe von den leuten also deutlich über
20 zentimeter aber hier ist mal die
gegenüberstellung als nächste pokémon
ist schulträger also die
weiterentwicklung von kno fenster und
rias eine sogenannte kannenpflanzen das
sind tropisch fleisch waschen
die entenfleisch auf englisch als das
ganze ding irgendwie pid ablehnt und
wenn ihr bei google eingibt pizza
planting bilder dann seht ihr wie
teilweise aus auffrisst oder irgendeine
fliege oder so aber hier ist meine
gegenüberstellung
das nächste pokémon ist sandra
weiterentwicklung von sander doch jeder
weiß es eigentlich schon damals ein
schuppentier das sind insekten fressen
die tiere also hauptsächlich ameisen und
termiten steht hier in meine notizen
schuppentiere haben keine zähne aber
dafür eine sehr sehr lange zunge
ich mag schuppentiere aber jetzt zur
gegenüberstellung export emails
traumauto mit seinem komischen hegel
achten drei händen der format soll ein
schabracken tapir sein dass der größte
vertreter der papiere schabracken tapir
format ist ja irgendwie und so ein
bisschen braun und dann oberhalb gelb
das ist bei diesen papieren nicht der
fall ist jetzt mit diesen schabracken
taktieren sondern die sind eigentlich
weiß schwarz und bisschen ähnlich wie
zebras also hinsichtlich der farbe sehen
die sich jetzt nicht so ähnlich aber man
sieht auf jeden fall ähnlichkeiten
deswegen hier mal die gegenüberstellung
das letzte mal dass ich heute wieder
live zeigen möchte bevor ich gleich zum
gewinnspiel komme ist bieber also diese
biene das weiß jeder dass es eine biene
darstellen soll die bolz aber keine
normale bühne sondern eine asiatische
riesen hornisse und die werden bis zu
fünf mal größer als normale bienen und
stiche von denen sollen äußerst
schmerzhaft sei hier weil die
gegenüberstellung damit wir sehen können
die große asiatische riesenrolle ist und
jetzt und gehwegen spiel ich habe
gesehen dass julien und emrah das ist
ein richtig großes gewinnspiel gemacht
haben
pellegrinis an euch beiden und die
hatten da halt so krasse preise wie
iphones und irgendwelche technik waren
und kamera
deswegen habe ich mal überlegt was ich
so verlosen kann und ich weiß ja nicht
ob man schon sieht aber vielleicht kann
ich ja davon dass irgendwie verlosen
oder so ich bin student ich verdiene
keine millionen und ich hab ja auch
keinen riesen technikpartner der wir
irgendwelche krassen luxusgüter gegen
die zur verfügung stellen kann aber ich
habe mir einfach gedacht in letzter zeit
zeigt die mir einfach dass ihr meine
videos total feiert und der support von
euch einfach mega krass ich wäre einfach
ein unmensch wenn ich euch nicht
versuchen würde irgendwas zurückzugeben
und das versuche ich natürlich irgendwie
täglich dadurch dass ich ein video
hochladen und mir die arbeit macht aber
für mich ist einfach keine arbeit
sondern es macht mir einfach spaß auch
sowas zu recherchieren für pokémons und
so deswegen habe ich jetzt einfach
gedacht ich fahr lose ein schwarzes
meine kisten aus dem lukas was ist ja
noch gar nicht gibt das heißt ihr werdet
es vor dem release am 10 oktober haben
und dazu verlose ich auch noch einen
zweiten gewinner mein buch als
überkommen beides zusammen mit jeweils
zehn signierten stinkern damit ihr
selber ein habt und vielleicht auch
freundin noch welche geben können oder
so ich weiß dass ich jetzt keine krassen
preise und ich habe mir einfach gedacht
vielleicht ist es ja ganz cool und ich
meine hier müsste eigentlich nichts
machen außer abonnent von einem kanal
sein und dieses video kommentieren mit
entweder buch oder kissen damit ich weiß
was ihr halt haben möchtet das
gewinnspiel startet ab jetzt als ihr
müsst einfach auf einem kanal sein weil
das gewinnspiel soll halt einfach nur an
meine zuschauer hier geht und nicht an
gegen den der einfach irgendwas gewinnen
will als wir müssen beim kanal abonniert
haben und jetzt einfach mal die
kommentare schreiben kissen oder buch
und das ganze gewinnspiel wird bis zum
15 oktober gehen also fast eine woche
lang und danach werde ich am 5 oktober
in dem video kurs zwei namen nennen und
diese leute dann halt bei youtube
anschreiben damit die adresse sagen und
dann sind nicht denen das heißt also had
the channel and comment nachher noch mal
kurz eine kleine zwischen rhein
blendungen hier mit meinem handy
aufgenommen ich hoffe man die qualität
ist natürlich sehr schwer mit dem handy
ich möchte einfach umgehen das sollte
jetzt kommentieren von wegen bei anderen
youtube kann man handys und computer
gewinnen und so also es ist wirklich so
ich habe hier keinen sponsor klären war
komplett mein kissen liegen und noch ein
paar bücher von mir ich verschenke ich
einfach mal steht das bitte nicht falsch
aber ich bin einfach kein mensch der
anderen menschen für etwas damit und den
im zuge dessen materielle güter schenkt
also ich meine ich möchte mich gerne
bereich dafür bedanke mich dann
irgendwann mal mit euch bei einem
fantreffen treffen und euch dann da zeit
mit euch verbringen oder so anstatt euch
jetzt irgendwie so materielle dinge zu
geben aber anders geht zeigen gerade
nicht deswegen habe ich halt gedacht
okay wenn wir das gewinnen möchte
kommentiert einfach mit kissen oder buch
und seit abonnent von meinem kanal und
deswegen habe ich jetzt nicht irgendwie
1000 ps3-konsolen gekauft habt ihr es
hier ist der mittlerweile schon draußen
bei der band halt voll viele neue leute
dazugekommen die mich nur deswegen
abonniert hätten und ich hoffe ihr
versteht was ich meine das soll wirklich
an meiner abonnenten gehen
danke dass ihr von dem video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen
und last auf jeden fall mein leid da
wenn ich das ganz normal machen sollen
mit den weiteren pokémon in trier live
und sonst findet ihr hier eine smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf klickt
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren wäre ja
ganz sinnvoll da könnt ihr auch an dem
gewinnspiel teilnehmen wenn dazu noch
kommentar schreiben und ihr findet hier
ein video eingeblendet wo ich pokémon go
in london gespielt habe war auf jeden
fall auch sehr witzig das war es jetzt
von mir viel glück beim gewinnspiel